we are
and
your colleagues
[Music]
to
really
2 we
easter
why
I
it
ladies and gentlemen hello ladies
and gentlemen the presidents the setting and
friends of the information we are
today for the first time
together the presidents of the three
institutions  and of the european central bank
to mark the taking
office of the new commission and of the
council
we find ourselves here at the house of
european history that this is the right
place to launch the building sites and
europeans under construction which should
encourage the  initiatives aimed at
making democracy more
modern europeans most effective in developing
new policies and european
reforms and policies
a hero by chance wanted the days of
this ceremony to coincide with the
second anniversary since the entry into
force of the lisbon treaty
this summer  a step forward towards
European integration
but never managed to highlight
aspects that are very important to me for the
development of European citizenship and
on the one hand the incorporation
into the treaties of the map of
fundamental fundamental rights which gives it
a value  legal binding and on
the other the rapprochement of citizens
to decision-making
a hero can thanks to the initiative and
citizen and a strengthening of the role of the
European parliament which represents them
g it is precisely in these dramas
necessarily of
representative democracy  that we have over
the last two months carried out a
complex exercise of control and
hearings of all the candidates of the
commission for 16.7 it is to ensure
that they are priests for
the work to come it is now
time to  stepping up to action
parliament stands ready to work as
one team with you to
continue building europe
we must turn the promises of the
last two months into an outcome that
improves people's lives
tackling climate change for
us c  is an emergence in the fight
against the rising cost of living
europeans want to see real action
president madam ursula von der
leyen asked in her speech to
parliament last week for our
support for a new start for
europe
effect that the executives of the four
institutions are together and if
today symbolize symbolizes this
new season a difficult path which
requires strong commitments from our
part in order to be able to meet the expectations
of the millions of European citizens who
mobilized in the last food elections
with the tower of the
highest participations next December 11
the commission will present to parliament
in an extraordinary session
these proposals aimed at limiting
the ecological impact within the union
through the new green deal
we are also working by giving in and already
at  the presentation of the conference on
democracy was born rope rather in
this museum of european history
took pictures of it in the boosts of the
founding fathers without their commitment without
the air courage we would not be here
today it is  a decoy tribute that
I would like to end a
reminder of the communities of trust
and solidity and solidarity that
inspired their projects and that it is
fundamental not to forget for these
new beginnings we must have
the ambition to do so that  tomorrow we
can say that we too have opened
a stronger in europe my work to
all to follow the president of the
european parliament mr charles
michel president of the european council
very dear a bear or dear christine
empty the place where the
roles are  we find ourselves this morning is a place
steeped in history also charged with emotion
and it reminds us of the strength
and richness of the European project in
its diversity of traditions
vitality of energy turn towards a
common project streams much to
discover i never know fyrom 10 diversity
living in fine as there is no identity
beds either baghdad in the green zone youth
and institutions were either badly seated
at the foot of the specials frink of b you
can't we are like manny obstacle to the
doubists a worthy son  lose 5
fruits and annuity flop from tweetie to
frisbee only box under cries
identify this disc diversity
she lies down a slope of a movie you
tube was born there and said anna de béring
love today left twitter all offer
skies  punished news puts a possible max
hoff to progress
n it is all ways to invent deficiency and
legitimate democratic and fit of day
union a lawn of karine office
actions hi bruges and that said we bump
falls and is just is safe on 22 d a
website  ringworm segaud 18 years of
all at what model of the challengers right
he wears a uniform especially timely
al fight with like a fight in spirit
change of tweetie jeff of yun junghee
mouth personality allaoui is all at
an international sale dreams like of
paris agreements of tweetie  also give
democracy and you find and transparency
and to open from behind straight alone slot
making mr de cannes this film itself
basin around the world
our public legislators also make
tice essentials in open skies a
democracy of tweetie also she
synchronization carried out which  purifie
baïtha briefing diop an extraction
service all weekends and unified
faith to do with the world with more it
is based world let's do is today we do
mot des noues québec
oui celebrates a new beginning with
great enthusiasm est autre
mythos new york tartine de  next five
years in soloist grounds where he reached
25 at the zone a bichon youtube and jen da
from lisbon tweetie is a riposte h and
from 10 a.m. to 11 a.m. instead of a family and
all the points that annoy 5 louis cher
gold  under the glasshouse
steen dear david let us be inspired
by this treaty and by the
founding fathers to transform
positive reforms into a daily reality for
every citizen the europeans I am
convinced expect a lot from us
their expectations are fair they are
strong they are ambitious  let
's work together tirelessly as a
team to give that extra soul
to the european project that brings us together
thank you madam race or the band'à line
for the european commission
dear christine schaer charles gide with
thank you very much for the invitation
it's very nice to  don't receive you
here thing cabins to lose and at 9:06
am
we are from guardians of it is very
special founding farmers pardus to
responsibilities too high availability
and strong spirit vanuatu thing of if
things continue too bad the
nonsense single market previous eight
economic opportunities and is your
duty to appraiser of internships
gray car not just treasurer night
with you but you're with some things you
have to build brick by brick and day by
day
thenergo took over from its sister of 17
million of people have taken stream
[Applause]
Mrs. Christine Lagarde President of the
European Central Bank
hello all my bed when a bad
day a gbagbo meeting and I
should speak French four
presidents together two men two
women
we are present in the museum of
the history of europe
our African friends often say if you do
n't know where you're going ask yourself where you're from you
don't know why holding as who
offers you came from you will find a
way welling over the last
decades europe to  to overcome so many
difficulties but I as president of
the European central bank
I also look at the last ten
years which have been said ten years of
repairing profound changes
the sovereign debt crisis the
profound technological modifications
the climate change of which finally the
international community is
certainly  the European community
is aware
it is a formidable challenge that awaits us
my hope as President of the
European Central Bank and in
coordination with my three colleagues and
friends it is obviously to move on from this
age of reparations that we have experienced
over the  last years at an age
of renovation and hope i have spoken
of a new policy mix for europe
do you know that the european union is the
largest economic region in the world we
must take advantage of this force
obviously it is  by doing so together
all four in our positions which
are ours and above all by
addressing all European peoples
as jean de la fontaine addressed
his fellow citizens by drawing inspiration from
reality and using the right words
to  tell the real stories
that is what we will hopefully do
thank you
[Applause]
the four presidents will now
gather in the center and the president of the
european parliament and of the
european council will hand over the treaties to the
president of the guardian european commission
treaties
[Music]
now continue the European anthem
on
the
this kill you' the ceremony thank you for
your presence
2 to
to
[Music]